alright thanks everyone for coming back
I'm going to more or less start off from
where I left off yesterday that's at
least for the first few minutes I did
manage to come I wanted to show you one
more construction of codes with all
simple locality I decided it wouldn't be
fair to you if I don't show you this
construction so I'll finish that and
then we will talk about something else
so let me just remind you we are
considering this notion of locality we
say that a linear code has locality are
all symbol locality are if each
coordinate is expressible as a linear
combination of our other symbols which
are other symbols depends on which
coordinated trying to express we were
interested in this question of what are
the trade-offs between the rate distance
and this new parameter called locality
and it turns out that you can get an
exact bound here if it generalizes the
singleton bound and this is the shape of
the bound it tells you that you need a
constant overhead for constant locality
and then what you expect for distance
right the proof is essentially an
algorithmic proof you know it's the kind
of proof which a computer scientist
might like alternate proofs papaya
pillows and demarcus they basically redo
the same proof but instead of linear
algebra they use the language of
information theory they show that if you
consider the total entropy in your
symbols as opposed to the rank of your
set then the proof will go through it
will generalize him into non linear
codes a very different proof at least it
looks very different to me using the
theory of generalized Hamming weights
was given in this work by a shuttle this
might be a proof it should appeal more
to a coding theorists a graph theoretic
proof was given by this work of bark and
Tommo this is a proof it might not be
able to community realist and you know I
look forward to the next prove this
space here several generalizations of
look at of code these kinds of codes
with locality have been considered I
already mentioned lon linear codes you
can talk about vector codes bring the
alphabet size Q into the picture and
asked what are the trade-offs once you
also care about Q
and then this other interesting variant
where right now we're just saying in
essence we say that each coordinate is
protected by something like a short
parity check you can ask for some more
powerful local protection like a short
local MDS code around each coordinate
and people have looked at variants like
this and basically all the lower bounds
and structure theorems they more or less
generalized in the way that you would
expect on to explicit constructions of
course with all symbol locality I showed
you this nice construction of
silberstein at all based on gabbi doolin
codes it gives you the optimal length
and all symbol locality but the alphabet
size was exponential in the block length
another construction which I didn't talk
about by tommo Papa your Pulis intima
kiss also gives you the same properties
but again q is exponential in the
encoding length ok for me k NN you know
i'm not going to distinguish too much
written there lastly let me show you
this bargain tamil construction which is
going to be based on Reed Solomon codes
and here we'll get linear alphabet size
linear in the block length so the
construction it's basically like Reed
Solomon codes except you don't take
monomials of every degree you take a
very special set of degrees so what is
the degree set well you take
non-negative integers but then you
decide ok so let's fix the locality
parameter R so you take the degree set
you decide that you don't like integers
that are congruent to our modulo r plus
1 drop all those integers and now you
want a code of dimension K so pick the
first gay integers where you keep
dropping every number which is odd
modulo arm-wrestle right so you can do
this and you'll basically terminate at
least I did this calculation last night
and this is where it ended the largest
number is of size K times 1 plus 1 over
R minus to ignore the minus 2 you're
picking are out of every r plus 1 number
so this is what you should expect and
then the polynomials are just univariate
polynomials with this degree set
evaluated at all points in FQ star
I know just use the stand if you want to
pound the distance and the locality of
this good the distance bound will just
be the standard bonford reed-solomon
codes that you have a polynomial of
certain degree it can have at most
degree many zeros so n minus degree many
more non zeros n minus this number by
sheer coincidence happens to be that
number i have written over here you just
do the you know moody over to the other
side you'll get n minus this quantity
and that's what you want the more
interesting thing is why does this code
have any locality at all because
reed-solomon codes don't have any
locality whatsoever so actually I
haven't specified the code completely
you need to be a bit careful in how you
choose the file size q so let's assume
that F Q star contains a subgroup a
multiplicative subgroup of size r plus 1
it contains G sub group size r plus 1
so basically all the elements in the
subgroup G they satisfy the property X
raise to R plus one equals one and now
you can partition fq star into cassettes
of this subgroup each cassette is of the
form a times G so even elements here
will satisfy a low degree equation which
is that you first divided by a and then
you apply the same equation right so the
cassette a times G consists of all
elements where X raise to R plus 1 and
essentially a to the r plus 1 ok so now
let me tell you what the groups of
symbols are which have some locality
property they are exactly the partitions
of F Q star into cassettes of G why is
it local when you restrict to one of
these cassettes when you are restricting
to one of these cassettes in essence
you're taking this polynomial and your
question ting it by the equation x raise
to R plus 1 equals some constant right
so everything is going to collapse to a
polynomial of degree at most are and now
the holes in the degree sequence worked
to your advantage because you omitted
all monomials which were r mod r plus 1
so actually you don't have any terms of
degree are you only have terms of degree
r minus 1 so restricted to these r plus
1 points you know everything is a
function of degree are but these when
you restrict them to these r plus 1
points you get a polynomial of degree r
minus 1 so it's a non-trivial
reed-solomon code which has distance to
so there is some dual constraint on
these which gets them together so that
is why you get locality up ok so it's
this was a little fast and furious but
you know it's a very simple and elegant
construction so what is the field size
here well you and this is a very general
construction we work with multiplicative
subgroups all you really need is to be
able to partition your space of
evaluation points into these small sets
which satisfies some low degree equation
right so it's a very general thing it
will comfortably give you alphabet size
field size linear in the length of the
code
alright so well so one very important
thing though this construction had this
much stronger property before last time
that when you puncture each of these
local groups in one coordinate each what
you get is an MDS code you could look at
this code and wonder does it have this
property and it's certainly not obvious
to me there might be a way to get it by
doing something clever in addition but
if you just puncture this right ok what
you're getting is a bunch of evaluation
points in FQ star now the space of
polynomials it's hard to argue that it's
MDS because yes it's univariate
polynomials but it's univariate
polynomial of much higher degree than
you expect these are polynomials of
degree 1 plus 1 over R times K so it's
not obviously an MDS code all right so
you get a smaller field size here but in
comparison to and I believe this other
construction of Alex and his co-authors
also has the stronger property that it
can correct any such functioning right
so these things seem to require much
larger feel sighs do they really this is
going to be the focus of the rest of
today's talk okay but before I get there
let me just tell you some other work
which people have done about you know we
have this very simple notion of locality
could you have even stronger notions so
this is a very interesting topic and I
don't have time to cover it but it
lately tell you where to look if you're
interested in this like firstly as I
said you know this notion of having
regeneration and notion of having
locality this seem like very natural
complementary notions and people have
asked can we combine these and have
corns with local regeneration so this
year the first couple of papers on this
there's probably more this other variant
I talked about where your code actually
has a short MDS code protecting each
information symbol with distance better
than right so again this
interesting in practice because it
allows for the following thing right now
if x1 is just protected by a parity
check equation when I am serving a
degraded read for x1 then I just need to
read all these other are symbols and
wait till all of them response but if x1
is protected by some kind of MDS code I
have a bit of flexibility here I just
ask all these nodes which participate in
these MDS code as soon as sufficiently
many of them respond I'm done right so
now okay this raises a whole other set
of questions like you know what is the
right way to set the threshold and so on
it seemed like an extremely natural
question which I was sure that someone
would have addressed and as it turns out
it has been addressed in this very
recent paper by kernan and his
co-authors where this they analyzed you
know how much of leeway do you want to
avoid these bottlenecks another notion
which has been studied is sequential
local recovery here what happens is that
many things fail you are able to correct
one erasure using just our reads okay
now you are able to correct some other
erasure maybe you couldn't have
corrected this before using a further
our treats so you go on and completely
locally you finish your decode so this
is again I find it a very natural motion
for the computer scientists in the
audience none of these notions are
exactly in aligned with what we think of
as locally decodable codes as David
pointed out last time I haven't really
defined what locally decodable codes are
I will shortly here is a notion which
comes very close to it they say that
okay what is locality it means it's a
group of our other things that you can
read to repair this node okay how about
if I have several disjoint groups right
one reason one reason this might be good
for you is that now you can serve not
just one read to this X one but several
parallel reads they send the first
person to read this groups in the second
person to read the other group and so on
right so this notion was introduced i
believe by wang and zhang and further
studied by barg and tom
here is the formulation of the problem
which comes very close to what we think
of as locally decodable codes so now
already from the rate distance trade-off
we know that the overhead you incur for
distance as small as opposed to the
overhead that you incur for locality the
reality you could say I want to correct
some d1 number of errors locally and d2
number of errors in all let's forget
about d2 you can get that by adding due
to additional parity checks if you know
if you need so let's just formulate
codes which can correct locally a
certain larger number of errors than
just one so in particular suppose I want
an NK linear code where even after D
arbitrary failures every information
symbol has locality are means that D
things failed somebody asked me for x1
let's say X 1 is one of these failures
now someone wants to read x1 I can still
serve this request by reading our other
things what r the rate distance
trade-offs for such a notion and this i
claim is essentially LDC is as computer
scientists know them just tuned to the
model of airasia's rather than errors
right so if you have these deep disjoint
local recovery sets then of course you
get this notion but you don't need them
disjoint it's basically some the gap
between vertex cover and maximum
matching in high regards and to start
for you know it's towards proving a
lower bound for this problem this bar
tamil lower bond which gets a nearly
optimal lower bound for this disjoint
parities model it seems like a good
stuff all right so now I've actually I'm
actually done with the first part of my
talk where we talked about a locality
now I in the remaining time I'm going to
talk about reliability of these scopes
so really if you're designing codes for
storage certainly locality is a good
property to hell
local regeneration is even better but
what kind of errors are you really
trying to correct if a code has a
certain minimum distance does that mean
it's reliable enough very try and
convince you that actually you might
want something stronger than just
minimum distance and then we will talk
about explicit constructions all right
so uh what kind of failures actually
happen when you're storing you know data
in this kind of huge data centers right
so that the thing which is very common
here is correlated failures which is a
lot of machines will fail at the same
time but it's not like one machine from
here one machine from there and so on
when these large correlated failures
happen it's usually for a reason that
you could have anticipated like all of
these are sharing the same power source
that blew up or they are sharing the
same network switch and something
happens and so on like even more
dramatically you can imagine and a lot
of storage systems now do this they have
data centers in different geographic
locations and you could imagine that for
some reason like you know maybe a whole
data center goes offline let's imagine
that you're storing data in redmond
boston mountain view cambridge china and
india and then one morning suddenly
inexplicably your whole Center in
Mountain View is gone it sounds like a
very you know unlikely scenario but
stranger things are known to happen in
practice so so this is the problem here
that you can have these large correlated
failures
at this time if I get fired I know
exactly why you want to cut out that
partners so yeah so you have so yeah I
should be good about my citations like
this example was suggested to me by Jake
Amash right so in addition to this it
addition to these huge correlated
failures so you have these huge
correlated failures and then
uncorrelated failures it's fine to
assume that these are independent so
here is a toy example that I'm going to
think about say we have four racks of
machines and for some reason a whole
rack could go offline okay and you have
about six machines per rack now this
correlated failure model means that
let's say that the machines fail
independently with some probability P
and drag failure is a much more unlikely
event let's say it happens with
probability something like PQ okay so
this means that there are some seven
failure patterns you know which come
about by failing a rack and then one
more machine which are more likely even
than five failure pattern just because
hi failures can only happen from five
independent failures but seven failures
you can see because a rat failed and
then one more machine feet and actually
this you know the scenario is kind of
very close to the kind of scenario that
we were actually dealing with when we
were designing codes for azure storage
it's not so much a rack failure as they
are taking a whole bunch of machines
offline at a time for upgrading this is
when they are at their most vulnerable
so they want to be able to serve request
to the machines which are offline and
also not lose data if there are more
failures yeah so in what is
communication
I used to work out there is low
correlation correlative failure due to
fading of the channel so the channel
goes down for a while the typical
strategy guys do in to leave is to break
up the correlation so that your
independent failure again yeah preacher
not apply the same I guess you I think
when you see the solution that I'm
suggesting it will look a lot like
interleaving to you so there what I'm
going to suggest is like look this
problem comes about because you insisted
on your code having a certain layout and
you should account for this layout in
the scores that you design for this
topology and when I say you'll see that
it's basically the same idea i guess as
interleaving that the errors if you have
a lot of errors they are well spread in
a way that you can handle them so yeah
oh so let's say that okay so concretely
let's say in this scenario we want to
tolerate one rack failure and some three
additional machine failures right the
first thing you could try is to use a
reed-solomon code with suitable
parameters since in the worst case we
are gunning for nine failures and greed
Solomon doesn't care which nine nodes
fail you do is you use a code which has
minimum distance 10 which would work
fine but the trouble with a layout like
this is even one machine fails then to
serve a read to that machine you are
reading a ton of data this is the
original reason we said we wanted to
something different from trade Solomon
codes the other solution to do would be
to use these LRC's that we got we saw
last time which were derived from gabbi
doolin codes right so basically what you
have is that each sorry yeah its symbol
here think of the topmost entry in each
of these as a parity check of the
symbols in that column write this code
has the very nice property that you just
puncture it if you puncture any one row
what is left is an MDS code which is
exactly what we want and in general when
when when one machine fails you can
serve it by just reading three other
machines now it so okay here's the point
I want to make a single rack failure he
leaves you with an 1815 for MDS code but
this is not something that you'll get
just from thinking about the minimum
distance because the minimum distance of
this code is 6 it is that the kind of
failure patterns that you care about are
exactly tuned to the kind of things that
it can correct well right okay so I also
it shouldn't surprise anyone that the
codes we saw last time happened to solve
this problem pretty well because this is
the problem you were trying to solve
initially when we were starting to work
on LRC's right but anyway so the point
is how do you come up with the notion
which captures things like this that
your code is good for the kind of
failure patterns that are very likely to
arise maybe I can I wanted to make a
rock thinking about it so hey you won't
still it relating to David's comment he
wants it or if any nine failures and
there is i guess 24 shoes 9 way and ways
that you could fail but not not any
night that's that's exactly the point so
if you wanted to write any 9 you have to
go is that it Solomon andalusia but now
you say well not any 9 are possible so I
just I'll just design for this specific
sense is that the same as in their
living that's what I'm trying to think
for a well maybe in a big sense that you
know then I think of interleaving the
nine sets of failures that you want to
deal with and design the code only for
those 99 sets that you care about
whereas I guess so here all I'm saying
is that the kind what this code is good
at tolerating is error patterns which
are spread across columns the kind of
six error patterns which will actually
make this fail is when you concentrate
all your errors you know I basically
take out x1 it's parity and everything
in this column right so things which are
considered on a few columns are hard
things which are spread across many
columns are easy so in that sense you
know I guess I there's a similarity to
interleaving with what I'm saying I
think what the
in wireless we usually don't use such a
huge alphabets and don't deal with the
razors right so their very nature is 24
but in reality if the errors are random
i can actually correct you know 40
errors and interleaving just makes the
errors loop these are they in water more
isotropic I think the arrows vessels
erasures is not really the one decision
but the main point I guess is probably
that if you just had the nine random
errors you have a code that control 89
random errors but you don't have a color
control 89 bursty any luck yeah but here
we are doing we will say okay if you
want any 9 where that's that would you
pay with it it Soloman but if you want
specific sets of nine I will design a
code for the specific so i guess it is a
little different no one goes the other
in wireless case it does MDS code I mean
you to relieve his tube we can correct
any line right and in the shuttle but
he's not going to do this well go to
deal with any 9 like he's going to
design the cords specific sets of nine
so inside I think that related because
you view interleaved njoy stenchley
saying you only focus on certain error
patterns right how do you believe you
get essentially independent errors so
it's not quite that so yeah so maybe
lets you know i'll show you what we do
and then we'll talk more about whether
you know it's i'm not saying it's very
different idea maybe in the details it's
slightly different ok so i guess what we
are going to say here ok so this code
here it can certainly it gives you a
stronger guarantee than minimum distance
which is that any row fails you're left
with an MDS codes such codes they have
been studied before in the context of
discouraged by Planck blom and hafner
they call these sector disc codes in
fact the guarantee here is even stronger
than any one row failing it's one entry
per column failing leaves you with an
MDS code such codes have also been
studied before and these are have been
called partial MDS codes all of these
are modules which people doing disk
storage rate kind of things they not
very different from us I guess they
independently said these specific
topologies are interesting to us ok so
what this notion of maximal
irrecoverable codes
basically tries to say that look if
correlated failures happen you know we
have good information about what things
are likely to fail as a correlated thing
so presumably in designing your code you
are already taking this into account so
your code has a certain topology which
occurrence for the kind of failures that
are very likely and then your code
should be as good as possible given this
to polish and you know the motivating
example really is reed-solomon codes
where if you have a certain number of
erasers and you have those many
equations then you can correct it we
want something similar here we see a
certain a racial pattern if we have the
right number of linear equations to
correct these which we have for these
well spread out error patterns we should
be able to correct this relation it's
all that's going on the set this up
formerly we are going to talk about
goods with described topology the
quality is a fancy name for something
fairly simple you have some variables
alpha 1 to alpha T these are the things
that as a code designer you get to
choose and then the topology is
basically given by a parity check matrix
where each entry now it could be a
constant or it could be a linear
function in the Alpha is I could say
affine function in the Alpha is and
capture both of these things right so
what does this do it basically encodes
things like locality constraints that I
want this to be a local parity check on
this group or I want something else to
be a sum of some other things which
could include both data and penalty
symbols it allows you to express
constraints like that now to instantiate
a code of this topology you just pick
the alphas and you want a good choice of
alphas as long as as I said if you have
enough equations you should be able to
solve an erasure pattern which is you
want you want a code we say that a code
is maximally recoverable if it's correct
every error pattern that is possible you
know so you have a certain set of
erasers think of these as variables you
have certain equations in these
variables these equations don't even
have the desired rank then you're lost
but assuming that they have the desire
track you
should be able to solve so you what is
your love puzzles anything yeah I'm
going to say that more precisely here so
have this parity check matrix where each
entry is a linear function in the oven
now somebody comes up with an erasure
pattern right and you say okay these are
the variables these are all the
equations I have in these variables are
these enough linearly independent
equations just thinking of these as
formal linear polynomials and if the one
thing the obvious necessary condition is
that you need enough linearly
independent equations if you have that I
want to be able to correct this pattern
so formally this would come down to
saying that a certain determinant is non
singular as a formal polynomial or that
if somebody somewhere is able to find
some choice of alpha is for which this
radiation pattern is correctable I want
my code to be at least that good you
know this is one choice of alphas which
is as good as every other choice of
alpha as possible it corrects anything
that you could correct by plugging in
alphas here okay so this is you know
it's weird this is a very strong and you
know we just trying to compare try to
come up with a clean definition here
let's do some concrete examples to see
what this would translate firstly it's
good to know that such things exist and
we have concrete examples of them so MDS
codes would fit this definition so what
is an MDS code you just have h global
equations on all the variables and you
know each coefficient in an equation is
an independent barrier but you get to
pick if you choose these according to
the reed solomon parity check matrix
then its maximal irrecoverable because
anytime you have enough equations you
can invert the matrix a more interesting
example is the one that we were talking
about earlier of LRC's now again here
I'm going to make a few divisibility
assumptions which I want the sweep under
the carpet alyseum are divided scale
artplus one device code length and so on
we want codes where there are two kinds
of constraints there are these local
constraints
which say the parity of each column sums
to zero in addition to these local
constraints you get to throw in H global
constraints on all the symbols these are
just equations which you decide what
coefficients you want there and by the
lower bound we saw in the last lecture
if you want an LRC of optimal length
right this topology is more or less
canonical you know so okay the
distinction I'm trying to make is this
you can only talk about maximal
irrecoverable codes once you fix a
topology LRC's is i define them just
give you some locality property there is
no talk of topology in the definition of
LRC's themselves but the proof which we
saw actually said that if you want an
LRC which gives you optimal length and
locality for every symbol then the
topology gets fixed ok so it's kosher to
talk about a maximal irrecoverable LRC
because with the right divisibility
restrictions there is a fixed apology
it's this one so when is a code with
this topology maximally recoverable well
here maximal recoverability is exactly
what we've seen before puncturing one in
each column leaves an MDS cool effect of
puncturing one in each column in effect
should be to just get rid of these
locality constraints and what you left
behind should be an MDS cool so here ok
and SD is maybe let me not say more
about that here the bottom line is that
we know constructions but they require
fairly large free sizes
I like to contrast this with maximal
irrecoverable tensor product codes what
is the topology here I've used the same
picture so it looks very similar but on
one hand you have this column parity
constraints and then you have h
constraints on each row these are not
truly global constraints their
constraints on a roll so certainly if
you choose these as well as you can what
you're going to see within a row is an
MDS code and then the columns satisfy a
parity check equation so when is such a
code maximally recoverable well the
answer is that we don't really know we
don't have a clean characterization of
what error patterns you should be able
to correct using such a cool the one
thing we do know which comes as
something of a surprise to me is that
it's not sufficient that each row code
sorry the row codes are all the same so
that this actually makes sense as a
tensor product okay it's not sufficient
that the row code just bmds there is
necessary obviously it's not sufficient
there are examples very small examples
we are tensing a reed-solomon with
parity check is not maximally
recognizable so where might such a
setting come up right so imagine that
currently you just have one data center
there you are using reed-solomon codes
like tomorrow you decide you want to use
for data centers the most natural thing
is to have just read solomon locally
within each data center and do some
simple exile across datacenters this is
exactly the code you'll have and I
believe Facebook has written a paper
saying this is exactly the code they
have read Solomon tensor with parity so
why reed-solomon maybe there are better
codes MDS codes that you could be using
yes maximal record ability is there if
you think of some sort of bipartite
graph very good yes that is so rancor is
making this very good point so if the
topology if there is no locality among
the parity checks then you can think of
this nice bipartite graph that you are
talking about the left-hand side is the
nodes the right-hand side is which
parity checks read which nodes now halls
theorem will give you a nice
characterization but in this case we
have some locality among the parity
checks themselves and that is the first
place where this breaks the it's not
clear what things should be correctable
yeah so sorry I should mention that this
this notion of locality was introduced
in this paper by jen huang and lee in
two thousand six or so and there they
made this up rudeness that for the
setting that you are talking about there
is an exact characterization of when
something is correctable we want to
generalize it to allow things like
locality for all symbols basically and
now it's not clear what the
characterization something about the
definition so then this is it possible
this one clearly maximal thing because
you said then how you define is
maximally yes there it is very clear so
this is just like identity testing so
there is some determinant which needs to
vanish oh yeah actually it's coming in
the next slide I didn't realize we
haven't talked about this yet so is
there one choice which is universally
good which will correct every error
pattern that this topology can correct
the answer is always yes for every
topology write a random code over a
sufficiently large field would do the
trick because basically what you're
asking for is that a bunch of
determinants which are basically
polynomials in your variable should be
nonzero just the choise Apple Emma tells
you that pic from a very large field and
almost surely all of these polynomials
will be nonzero so there exists this one
setting of alphas which is as good as
any other setting if the setting
corrects that error factor and so will
this in fact there are many such
settings a random setting is likely to
do the job thing
so these alphas are the coefficients and
yet so these are the things that you get
to design they may not be as simple so
once you start doing things like parity
relations among the parity checks right
then the meaning of alphas becomes a
little fuzzy so just say these are
variables that you're allowed to choose
which will specify the code I I'll show
you a couple of concrete examples of
what these alphas are actually we've
seen concrete examples right so for
instance here you have these local
constraints that the parity of each so
we'll see an example shortly and then it
might I also because I'm also a little
confused it could be for this question
is it a new speakers confused yeah I
know this is the best yeah I don't
actually know this specific oh yes
clearly as men can said if if you ask me
if I choose all the koi fish you give me
the linear equations but you don't give
me the coefficients right yes the
question is design the coefficients so
that everything is as linearly
independent as possible could be yes
yeah so this is like general position so
justice yes so now what you said before
is going back to you know network coding
multi casting says just randomly choose
these things in a huge fields fanciful
says you cool again so now if a question
that is open as far as I understand is
an explicit design of these things can
come to that exactly the question you're
asking here is different you hear you're
asking you don't even know the flows so
you're asking why why can't i just say
he's actually giving the rest of my talk
for me so this is actually an even
that's an even better dig so they'll be
a very smooth transition right so yeah
so nylon so why do we okay so we have
this theorem which says that look I
don't understand what error patterns I
want to correct but random does it why
do I need to bother to understand these
error patterns that might be a concern
if you are trying for an explicit
construction because you know in an
explicit construction it seems like you
need to understand what things are
trying to correct to prove that your
construction so what is the whole point
of explicit constructions right so
firstly random over a la
field will work but how do you know that
it works maybe you were unlucky and you
know you happen to pick up that pattern
and then when you deploy it everything
crashes ok now let's imagine this is not
a concern because really code lengths
are short and by you know running it on
some cluster for four days weeks maybe
we'll be able to verify it the bigger
concern I claim is really this large
field size ok so I wanted to tell you
more about why this field size is so
important but that will take up a lot of
time which I don't have so very briefly
let me just tell you that this is how
decoding encoding and decoding both will
work you have your parity check matrix
that gives you some alphas now what
you're going to do is you have these
huge streams of data we're just going to
stream through this computing this inner
product alpha 1 X 1 plus alpha 2 X 2
till alpha and excellent ok so you have
to do this finite field multiplication
there that is really a bottleneck
because this is happening not just at
the time of encode not just the time of
decoding but also when you are encoding
so you want your what you'd really like
is that this finite field be just a few
bytes long something like two bites
three bites you know you'll have a
lookup table of logarithms you can speed
these things are if the field size gets
really large you basically have to do
matrix vector multiplications and this
really slows you down even at encode
time so big field sizes are a bottleneck
if you cannot get maximal you're a
curable codes over a small field you
lose something suboptimal but with two
byte encoding lens but by the same token
you couldn't care much about
explicitness field size is what really
matters usually random codes are bad
because we don't know how to decode them
but this is decoding from erasers this
is how it works you lose x1 you go look
at your parity check matrix and say ok
how do i recover x1 ok it's this linear
combination of these other machines
which I still have and now you just you
know request the data from those
machines who knows if they'll give it to
you once they give it to you you're just
doing this one inner product alpha 1 X 1
X 1 is alpha 1 x this thing plus that
thing and so on so it's all about the
field sizes
the code is explicit or was found by a
computer it affects what this alpha one
is and you know we couldn't care less
about that right so it's all really
about the feel sighs so first thing you
could ask maybe there's a better
analysis of the random construction you
know they're doing this huge Union bound
over all these determinants maybe random
actually works over much smaller field
lens feel sizes the answer to this is no
it's an emphatic north is a very nice
result biko party and Mecca I fear this
is something that coding theory is 714
30 or years and you know I'm going to
find out right now but here is what they
proved if you just want an MDS code the
simplest of all topologies you are
taking a k plus D minus 1 k could you
want to know when is it MDS well the
usual Union bound argument will tell you
that it's MDS for field sizes like K to
the D and they show that that's very
close to tight in the sense that if your
field size is something like smaller
than K to the D minus 1 times some
constant there's only an exponentially
small chance that a random construction
is in fact MDS so random actually needs
a large field size to succeed on the
other hand we know explicit
constructions reed-solomon codes where
the field size is k plus D so this is an
emphatic victory for explicit
constructions the whole problem is that
this reed-solomon construction it's so
delicate that you just you know you
change the problem just a little and
then we have no clue how to construct
explicit goals as i show you sure so the
main motivation for finding explicit
constructions is the field size here
it's all about the field size so have I
answered your question ok ok so I'm just
going to talk about this one topology
now for the rest of the talk which is
maximal irrecoverable LRC's you have
these local constraints on the parity of
each column then you have global
constraints on all remaining data
symbols and we want every puncturing
that could be MDS to be MDS
if you make your land just a little bit
longer yeah such big size yes um you
mean this lower bound would break for if
you insist of except MDS but if you just
relax it'll be some time now right
becomes the Nek afterlife right so I
think such a thing would be greased such
a thing would be reasonable but ok so in
situations like this yeah you're really
doing you need a whole lot of things to
be MDS at the same time you need
exponentially so that is a one MDS code
in these things I need exponentially
many things to be MDS all together so I
don't know you're right I don't know
what random does for this even a
weakening like you're saying as long as
it doesn't blow your length up too much
ought to be reasonable so here it's just
not clear to me what random does and we
can beat random for thanks it's an
important point right ok so in this in
this setting the upper bound for random
will be pretty bad because as I said you
need a whole lot of MDS codes we know we
can get it with exponential field size
and I should also cite this other
construction which would also give you a
maximally equitable with exponential
field size what is the lower bound for
random well this is at least as hard as
constructing one MDS code so at least K
to the H so what is K an edge so here is
the number of data symbols etches the
number of global parities after
functioning you want ok + HK MDS code so
we do two things we give a basic
construction which gives you a field
size of gate to the H right so depending
on how you want to think about random if
you want to compare yourself against the
upper bound that random gives then we
are meeting we are beating that
comfortably but perhaps the more
reasonable thing is to compare yourself
to the lower bond we essentially meet
that we have a second construction which
actually does better than random for
suitable parameters
and these constructions are fairly
simple and clean to describe so that's
I'm going to take about ten minutes now
to show you these constructions and then
I'll wind up so what is the problem
description it's very simple maybe I
have it written down here no so actually
can we switch off the projector thank
you
okay so what is the problem that I'm
trying to solve I want so I want to
think of my symbols as arranged in an r
plus 1 times n over R plus 1 cream I
want the code which has two kinds of
equations one is local parity checks on
the column which says summation X i J I
goes from 1 to r plus 1 is equal to 0
for all columns and then I want H global
constraints right side of the form
summation alpha i comma j sorry as alpha
IJ k x IJ is equal to 0 for k how i used
k already i have select me just a
different alphabet let's call this n4l
in h so these are the two kinds of
equations that I have and I want the
code to have the property that
puncturing one entry per column leaves
me with an MDS code so why did I insist
these coefficients are 1 it's not
important you could rescale the symbols
or something like that so let's just say
this is the problem that we want to
solve so the trouble with this is that
you don't want one MDS code you want a
whole bunch of MDS codes you want to
hold much of course to be MDS at the
same time thank you so what is the basic
construction of MDS codes that we are
going to use is going to be a slightly
inefficient version of reed-solomon
codes okay so let me just present to you
now a family of goals which are based on
linearized polynomials they are more
inefficient than reed-solomon but they
have other nice properties so let's just
consider codes of some length m which I
will relate to n later and we want H
parity checks we are going to choose
them of the following shape alpha alpha
1 squared alpha 1 to the fourth alpha 1
to the crew to the h minus 1 so each of
them and you have MLM
alpha 1 through alpha M here so this is
my parity check matrix for some code on
M elements which has H parity check
equations then is a code like this MDS
this is basically asking if I have h
such elements when is the determinant in
Venice the determinant non zero so very
clean characterization of that this code
is MDS if alpha 1 through alpha m.r.h
wise independent over FB so alpha 1 to
alpha m are coming from some extension
field of f2 you can think of them as
vectors over f2 this says that any H
subset of these guys should be linearly
independent over f2 the proof is exactly
what you think if you just take the
square determinants but you have h of
these alphas and you say where is this
determinant non singular its non
singular exactly when alpha 1 through
alpha H are linearly independent over if
it's obvious that if they are linearly
dependent then by linearity you'll get a
relation between the columns of the
matrix that is also a sufficient
condition if they are independent then
the determinant is nonzero so now what
we want to construct an MDS code is a
collection of vectors alpha 1 through
alpha M such that any H sub set is
linearly independent over f2 minimizing
the field size amounts to minimizing the
dimension in which these vectors live so
here is the problem now come up with
these M vectors which are H wise
linearly independent and do it in the
smallest dimension possible this sounds
like a very nice linear algebra problem
and it is the problem of constructing
good binary error correcting codes
because take the parity check matrix of
any binary code which has lent m and
minimum distance h plus 1
so take a binary code binary linear code
of length m and min distance h plus 1 so
now look at its columns any H of these
columns better be linearly independent
over f2 otherwise you'd get a code word
which has weight only H so now what is
the dimension in which they live this is
exactly the number of parity checks you
have to throw in in order to get a code
of distance H naively it would be h log
m but by the bch construction you can
get something like H over 2 log m and
it's because of this factor of 2 that
you will get alphabet size so you can
take alpha i's belonging to F Q where Q
is something like em to the H over 2 so
we're doing better than that random
construction using PCH so now these are
the kinds of codes that are going to
show up in our construction of maximal
irrecoverable LRC's so again the plan is
exactly the same these parity check
matrix is are going to have the ship
alpha IJ raised to 2 to the l minus 1
right so what I do is that I assign some
alpha IJ to each symbol here and then I
say that my global parity checks are
exactly of bishop you take your alpha
raise it to various powers of 2 so alpha
is the first parity check alpha squared
for the second alpha to the fourth for
the third and so on and so forth all
right and I claim that by suitably
choosing the Alpha eyes will be able to
get the stronger property so let's see
that this is the that this is indeed
true so let's imagine now so sorry is
the description of the code clear to
everyone so now let's imagine that we
have a puncturing one per column and
just to make my notation simple let
stir the case where the puncturing Zahl
happen in the last row you'll see
exactly that you know it's only a change
of location so all these symbols X pi
comma r plus 1 are gone we want to argue
that we are left now with an MDS code
how do you do that well you just
eliminate X r plus 1 using from each
column you eliminate the last symbol by
writing it as the sum of the other
symbols oh gee so now we've used this to
eliminate the missing symbols let's plug
this back into this equation so this was
a summation over i comma j so let me
tell you what is going to happen and
you'll see if it actually happens the
effect of eliminating this last row is
going to be that all these numbers here
they get shifted by that alpha you take
all the numbers in each column at alpha
r plus 1 comma 1 to them take all these
coefficients in the jth column you add
this to them and the code you get is
exactly this kind of code with these
constants for each entry so let's see
why this is the case I'm taking this
equation I'm putting it into this thing
here and I'm tempted to write on the
wall because it will be most convenient
but maybe I should write down cute right
so I have this summation over j
summation over i going from 1 through r
plus 1 of this quantity where what i do
is i write it now as a summation of i
going from 1 through our alpha IJ due to
the l minus 1 x IJ plus alpha r plus 1
comma j times summation X I'll i going
from 1 through r plus 1 raised to the
power 2 to the l minus 1 so basically
what happens is that this thing I can
add it to each and everything here and
rewrite this as nothing but summation of
this X IJ
okay and then by linearity I can take
the two to the l minus one out and say
that so just using simple linearity the
effect of this is to shift all these
alphas by the same element from the
bottom row so now they're going to use
this fact we want is good to be MDS so
we came up with this new table of
numbers where every element was shifted
by r plus 1 Komachi the same shift was
applied to elements in a column we want
this collection to be h wise independent
so what is a linear combination of H
elements of this kind it is a sum of at
most two edge of the Alpha HS and
moreover it's a nonzero-sum yeah so why
is it non zero the only possibility for
cancellation comes from multiple
elements in the same column because they
all have the second element which is the
same so if I add an even number of
things the second thing disappears if I
add an odd number of things then it's
hanging around it but these first
elements they cannot cancel out right so
some of H alphas of the form alpha IJ
plus alpha r plus 1 comma J equals so a
non-trivial sum equals a sum of at most
2 h alpha IJ s right so now if we want
the stronger property from our
construction we just need to choose the
alphas to be 2 H wise independent
instead of H wise independent again bch
will do this for us you know the factor
of two that we it's a factor of two that
we got here it will be cancelled by bch
and you can do this over a field size f
q where q is equal to M to the sorry
it's M is now something like key resize
care to the H
maybe I did that a bisque a bit
basically so let me just say it again if
you just wanted the MDS property it
satisfy its sufficient that you have to
hy you just have h wise independence to
get the stronger property you just don't
need that the alphas themselves are
linearly independent you're going to
consider various shifts of the alphas
where you take one entry from each
column and you shift everything in that
column by that entry this is the new
collection of things that you want to be
h wise independent one way to do this is
to choose the alphas themselves to be to
H wise independent that gives you a feel
sighs something like k to the inch or I
was going to tell you a bit more about
the second construction but maybe since
lunch is in the offing uh skip that and
just wind up with some nice open
questions that I think Oh can hear the
projector thank you
sound it seems related to this other
construction with linearized polynomials
but here it's better because you have h
in the exponent of n oh yes yes yes so
I'm still thinking about this setting
where H is small compared to you know
compared to the other parameters so ke
to the H in that regime is better and
maybe yeah so yeah I think that's the
only I mean also or maybe if you want to
think of large H you don't use bch you
some other binary linear code then I
don't know how they compare it's a
really general template for constructing
a code I should mention that in some
cases you know b/ci just not for some
specific distances dch is not the best
construction know there are improvements
there and then you get things that even
by this construction I think you'll get
things that clearly beat eh so we got
something like k to the edge there is no
reason that you cannot get these
maximally recoverable lrc is over linear
field size like reed-solomon and maybe
some clever modification of reed-solomon
will do the trick for you so it's an
interesting question whether you can
construct such LRC's over linear size
field we understand nothing about a
tensor code when its maximal
irrecoverable I think it's a very nice
question we'd like explicit
constructions to do that it feels like
you need to understand what kind of
error patterns we are trying to correct
in the first place and this question of
dust this notion of maximal
recoverability require large fields
could it be that there are some natural
topologies for a lower bound maybe we
are even happy with relaxing the notion
of what is a natural topology but are
their natural topologies over which you
can only get maximal irrecoverable codes
by taking the field size to be extremely
large which is exponential in the length
or I don't know if we don't have any
example where you require a non-trivial
alphabet size super linear right so
proving a lower bound also would be very
interesting
alright so let me just are so I'm done
now I'm going to leave you to Alex from
tomorrow onwards but before I wind up I
just wanted to say a few thank yous
that's the Simon's Institute for
organizing this wonderful semester and
to David and record for inviting me to
give this talk I a lot of what I've said
today is you know it's basically based
on work in collaboration with people
both in Azure storage and ennis are
especially Sergei who is here today it's
so I'd like to mention Brad calendar
chenguang at an obese Hussein symmetry
and Sergey and lastly this was work done
at MSR Silicon Valley you know a
fantastic lab which as you know was
closed a few months back and a lot of
our ideas were influenced by our
colleagues there so you know I'd like to
thank them in absentia any questions
no the slides are the best better you
know there I I thought about this I
think it's too early for a survey
there's lots of when there is but since
there has been a little yeah I mean oh
sorry regenerating Kurds there are maybe
more than one very good service around
fair enough okay up to two thousand
eleven or twelve there is but this is
2014 stuff if you want a good survey
think about regenerating codes um so
which of this if anything is then
actually implemented in its introduction
good yeah so these actually are LRC's
are in implement are being implemented
in Azure the codes which we use are very
similar to this topology it's a baby
version of this topology they really
cared about upgrades and you know having
good distance after upgrades so the
precise property they wanted was
puncturing should we made with an MDS
code this has been in a production in
Azure since 2012 in fact this was the
motivation for me and Sergey to put this
lower bound to see whether the codes
which suggested or anything close to
optimal since then even other things
like windows you know I don't know how
many people use Windows but there's
something called windows storage spaces
where if you want to set up a cluster of
60 machines they'll give you various
kinds of erasure coding options Reed
Solomon is one of them LRC's are other
of them I also believe we've published
everything we've done I believe these
codes are being used by other companies
you know but this is just my speculation
I i think there's publicly available
things which say that the cost savings
from moving to lrc as opposed to reach
Solomon R of the orders of hundreds of
millions of dollars this in this
construction that you say you use the
the local parity is the grey ones are so
ya know so actually what you said before
as a cancer construction or so I'm using
the same picture because i'm lazy right
so then i talked about LRC's these great
things depend on everything when I talk
about tensors they only depend on the
row and then it's the same code used in
every row so that you have the tensor
product structure in both kisses you get
to pick only H equations in the former
they can depend on everything in the
latter they only depend on things in the
room so this is what our general
definition allows you to do it says
these things depend on these symbols you
decide how the tensor is just that it's
the same linear equation is the same
code in every row and the column has a
parakeet jack equation cxr say it's a
very different thing right because if
you look at the other sorry I'm talking
about LRC's here in li sees you want
necessary you will see a non-trivial
code within each row right because these
other constraints are global in a tensor
each row is also a code word it's an MDS
code so they are very different I
shouldn't have used the same picture I
apologize for that
yeah so here this is a code word okay
every row supports a code word in the
lrc case you know that'll trolls need
not have any local structure do you have
any conjecture on when the the tents of
things Emma ah not a conjecture which I
can state succinctly in that time we
have before lunch where you are so do
exactly some special cases where you
connect to the truth is efficient of the
yeah okay CJ well multiple very typical
so let me mention that I think maybe
circuit things this way to that this is
a fantastic candidate for a lower bond
of simple innocence you can't get these
things over but even for the way to it I
don't know not this not this some some
variant of this we'll talk later it's
clearly time for lunch now so on that
note oh let's thank crush it again for
great